Government of
works Thanks to 1 agreement
withanticonstitucionales matches
and extreme left
and its activity involves meeting its agenda,
the rule of law,
freedoms,
with privacy
and daily safety
of Spaniards.
Criminals in the street,
appointments of colleagues
to senior justice officials,
change of the rules of the game
to validate their positions,
criminalize judges for their decisions.
And do you have the value
to criticize us for our rule of law
in Hungary?
The Yel and the constitution would allow nothing,
never do this.
You use recovery funds
with a lot of opacity
while blackmailing the commission
not to give funds to Hungary.
Commissioner,
how long are you going to take action against?
Until when are they not going to take
measures against the Spanish government
or they only take it against conservative governments
that represent values such as freedom and the family?